gentlemen wilderness weekend is upon us
there will be no video games there will
be no internet pads
this weekend you have two parents me and
mother nature
and i am mother nature's brother
brother nature but you can call me andy
or
brother nature your call thank you andy
brother nature
for the last three years i have served
as troop leader
of the pawnee rangers this is our
handbook
i wrote the whole thing myself all right
safety basics donna can you tell me why
it's bad to look down the barrel of your
gun
is that a trick question no donna don't
please
rule number one do not point the weapon
at a person
that includes your own face donna now
every year before we go on our first
hunt we do a toast
so grab a beer
to the hunt you're here and to the
hunters
the only way to defeat the beast is to
find the beast within
pretty good
ron your toes sucked the traditional
toast is
to the hunt and it is said by me
nope follow me just one second now hey
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa run run run run run
run what's going on my ex-wife tammy is
back
yeah i saw her in the courtyard no my
other ex-wife tammy tammy won
i have accrued 228 personal days
starting right now i'm using all of them
while i'm gone you're in charge
also i keep a sizeable supply of ground
chuck in my desk
remove it or it will begin to smell
godspeed
ah jeez here is our official retreat
schedule it divides our time
evenly between work and play come on
everybody let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming great
attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something i
mean yes my daughter might think she is
old enough to be sexually active with
her boyfriend but i'm sorry
16. that that just seems too young to be
on birth control you know i was 24
when gayle took my virginity would say
we just stand here
in silence and think of ideas
for projects you know what i should do i
should lead
a teen abstinence workshop
that might be incredibly effective
i love that sound
i've been shot
i've been shot
somebody shot me in the head
hey okay how are you feeling how are you
feeling are you dizzy dizzy
are you light-headed when i look at my
palm i see a lady's mouth french kissing
a dog
well the pain medication i gave you is
pretty strong donnie uses it for
menstrual cramps how many did you take
seven eight better wash them down with
plenty of fluids
no ron you cannot drink scotch with this
you're going to need to purge
right now okay oh yeah no i'm not
wasting
20 years yes can you open his mouth
leslie what open his mouth
no open his mouth okay i'm not making
myself throw oh
ryan you're sorry we have to do this
let's
well good news is ron is resting
comfortably
i offered ron a job last month and he
turned me down
and it literally broke my heart but
now i see that this is truly where he
belongs
way to me ron you're really getting it
done man
he can't hear me okay let's begin the
barbecue oh
hey little guy what are you doing oh no
everyone meet your
no no meat why are you doing this to us
well in my opinion not enough people
have looked their dinner in the eyes and
considered the circle of life
this is your dinner his name is tom
burn seriously no i understand that it's
hilarious but that is his given
christian name
tom is very smart and incredibly loyal
he's basically a dog
a dog we're going to cook chew and
swallow dude there's kids around here
good point which one of you youngsters
wants to help me drain the blood from
this animal
if you do a good job i'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
play ball
hey ron you're not gonna slaughter that
pig here are you
not to worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want i am
the director of the parks department
and this is a park it's not a parks
thing it's against like three laws and
a dozen health codes
fine barbecue is postponed until i can
go pick up some meat from the food and
stuff
let's go tom no pig tom
rangers as a reward for coming on this
trip i have gotten you each two gifts
go ahead open them
huh what is this that is a canvas sheet
the most versatile object known to man
it can be used to make
tents backpacks shoes stretchers
sails tarpaulins and i suppose in the
most dire of circumstances
it can be a surface on which to make art
what's the second gift the second gift
is the box itself
you have 10 minutes to assemble a
shelter using
only your two gifts go
this homemade bulgogi is so delicious
kayla
this is the best korean food i've ever
had i would say it's almost as good as
lukewarm beans from a can right ron
i'm trying to teach my boys about
rationing food and your self-indulgent
ethnic food court isn't helping
goddesses let's go over our schedule for
this afternoon
we have hiking and then capture the flag
and then a puppet show about the bill of
rights
set to party in the usa by miley cyrus
and then we have lasso training
and a s'mores off
so it's on our schedule mr swanson we
have one activity planned
not getting killed
hey there you are thanks for meeting me
here
well if you'd have held him here instead
of that conference room i would have
come to more meetings
i got to tell you leslie establishing
this national park right next to pawnee
is quite an accomplishment
this is a fine piece of land you saved
thank you ron
you want to run it the superintendent of
bryce canyon retired
and i convinced the superintendent of
this park to transfer shuffled a few
things around
the point is someone needs to take care
of this place now thought it should be
you
i well first of all
i would be working for the federal
government your job would be to walk
around the land alone
you'd live in the same town you've
always lived and you'd work outside
you'd talk to bears next argument
well there must be dozens of people
gunning for this job i wouldn't want you
to ruffle any feathers
am i even qualified well a few people
might be annoyed but they'll get over it
and as far as your qualifications
you're ron swanson stop being a dummy
and accept
when do i start oh today i already
accepted for you i still remember how to
forge your signature
let's go meet your staff
pawnee national park rangers this is ron
swanson
your new superintendent and boss
rangers my name is ronald ulysse swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as i'm not
looking for any new friends
end of speech well said
thank you leslie you're welcome ron
okay time to go to work
laugh with me buddy just with me
buddy don't let her get the best of me
buddy don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
you